you know who I think the biggest fear is
in this whole thing is Alex Jones what
we might have found his Road to
Redemption if he just keeps interviewing
people crazier than him he looks forcing
him to be like that's not true now we
can't just hate people love Jewish
people but I also love cheese
oh man well I have to disagree with that
yeah you know you've gone off the deep
end when Alex Jones is interviewing you
and he's the rational when he's got to
keep you in line I like Hitler I don't
like Hitler and I know you're trying to
be shocking with that I'm not trying to
be shocking I thought this man was
Barbara Walters
you can't just say these things he kept
giving them outs too he's like you're
not really not like people are saying
you're saying you like the Nazis but
you're being hyperbolic and then I'm a
Nazi yeah yeah yeah yeah poor Kanye poor
Kanye but it is exhausting right are you
guys exhausted by it yet yeah dude yeah
I'm just exhausted by it yeah yeah I was
on I was on the pbd podcast Patrick but
David was great and uh we were
discussing it and it's just like
it's really fun Kanye is trying to do uh
you know what what he does for music but
like with thought yeah like he's just
trying to like hand pick a few
interesting sentences that he's heard
and then organize them into one cohesive
thought right that's how you make a beat
because that's how you make a beat and
he's done that throughout his career and
it's been absolutely amazing he just
grabs and puts them together and he is a
real talent for that but with thinking
yeah you can't do it's like there are
political parties spend millions and
millions of dollars on these things
called think tanks and they organize
thoughts and it costs millions of
dollars and tons of people who went to
[ __ ] Harvard Yale Ivy all the
smartest people in the world that have
nothing else to [ __ ] do sit around
and think yeah and even they can't
convince us to stop getting abortions
even they can't convince us to stop
going to work yeah you know it's just
like but millions of dollars to spend
there's probably been like 20
interesting thinkers in history we're
still talking about Socrates yeah it's
true like there's only a few people
throughout history yeah where you still
remember the [ __ ] they said you're like
I might have been onto something yeah a
little bit right and Kanye is just
trying to like remix and it's just not
how it works it is easier to make beats
than think one thousand I hate to break
it to your musicians
it's easier to make beats than things
also to sample better producers you know
what I mean like sample more Socrates
less mind comp yeah there you go like
just do more like I think therefore I am
people be like man this Kanye guy's
really deep yeah like Jim Carrey sampled
but he sampled more like esoteric [ __ ]
yeah wait what or like Jim Carrey when
he was like oh nothing means anything
like he was just like pulling thoughts
he was stealing jokes
were doing the whole like they're super
philosophical yeah philosophers were
like yo they're actually taken from a
lot of good philosophers here and like
it doesn't make a ton of sense but their
thoughts are there's a lot to it or
something yeah Kanye is taking from the
worst philosophers well it's so
interesting because he's like
he's taking from Jesus
like it's just fascinating to Fire and
Ice
crazy yeah that is wild what do you
think about it to be like to look at
Jesus be like wow this is the perfect
human being like the way that he is able
to forgive and welcome people into his
kingdom and then Hitler who's like you
have brown hair
the least forgiving guy in history sweet
and salty bro that's it that's what it
is like in no way is he listening to the
ideology of Jesus and going I don't know
if this Hitler [ __ ] lines up with that
at all yeah musically kind of what he
does like he'll take rock music
now we're getting it Jesus wasn't enough
for him isn't that crazy that's crazy
he's a bad Christian Jesus should be
enough you don't need Hitler yeah I'm
not even Jesus should be enough for you
but Kanye is such a bottomless pit
that he can't even be filled by the
greatest filler in history
as Mary fam you know what what what what
what because she was pregnant with him
she was pregnant with God yeah yeah
exactly first me too yeah
like literally Kanye could have sampled
the devil and I think people would not
be as mad if he was like oh I'm a
Satanist now people would be like way
more forgiven you just can't go Hitler
because not even atheists like Hitler
yeah like yeah like God sucks but they
wouldn't go as far to say Hitler
you can't do that about Hitler and art
school yeah you can identify as a
Satanist you can't identify it Nazi no
that's no no no believe in the epitome
of all evil but that's not bad as him
what the [ __ ] is this guy talking about
whoa Hitler went to hell and the devil
was like it's great to meet you yeah
I've heard a lot about you
everyone's been chatting about you I
think he went there he's like you took
it a little far
I hope I could torture people like you
down here at all
that was evil even thanks for warming up
my seat
wow yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a
that is that is a wild thing right there
yeah even an atheist
recognizes that Hitler is crazy yeah
yeah whoa yeah
no not even atheists a Satanist yeah
yeah would be like yo this is crazy what
is the purpose of saying religiously
what do they teach you about like like
what do they teach about Satan he's a
bad guy I used to be an angel great at
music
and then uh got cast away because it was
Pride he got cast into hell yo Jiffy why
are you laughing at this is that not
true come on what is that
is that not true let me find out Mark
knows less about God than soccer bro
but wait wait is is that not true
responsible for all the evils in the
world
would be responsible for Hitler yeah
but the Jedi became the master there it
is there it is a young Anakin yeah yeah
exactly is it Anakin yeah yeah now
here's the question
if
Kanye likes Hitler who's the embodiment
of all the things that Satan represents
is Kanye not a Christian is he actually
a Satanist
is he using Christianity to bring people
to the dark side what did uh God always
say about Satan uh he's a ugly guy no I
don't know right didn't isn't he like a
false prophet but he's a liar in the
father he lies everything that you
always wanted he'll come to us
everything which is fire beats yeah fire
beats and also relationship with God
Christianity
didn't he do that um what was that
Sunday service yeah what was that Sunday
service for oh are you saying this day
are you saying is the Antichrist I'm
just saying I'm just saying it seems
like something who's the Fallen Angel
Gabriel
I don't think so can you fall no no I
think these clumsy ass angels
yeah okay a bunch of other angels went
with him he did that yeah they chose up
Cox
is that the first manosphere dude I
don't know who I'm more tired of the
[ __ ] is atmosphere or I don't know if
I'm sorts out of the Mansfield or
outside I think the guild